so i'm just briefly going to give an
overview
of of where we are now in amazon
text-to-speech
um in in the latest work we're doing on
making alexa sound
more natural and human when we
communicate
with engaging
ai and if we look at the topics that i'm
going to talk about in this brief
presentation i'm going to divide into
four sections there's
naturalness expressivity semantically
aware
synthesis and what's called always
getting better
which is about context aware synthesis
so i'm going to go to each of these in a
little bit more detail
throughout the presentation but it's
going to be a bit of a whistle-stop tour
of where we are with tts at the moment
so if we take a little bit of a
background to this
well before 2016 or so there were two
approaches to doing synthesis
there were statistical parametric
synthesis methods
and these were very flexible different
types of positivity could be applied
but they lack the naturalness in terms
of segmental quality audio quality that
a human being is capable of
and then you have the other set of
synthesis systems called unit selection
or u selection hybrid
tts systems and these could achieve very
high
naturalness but were very constrained in
the type of
sensors they could produce or the level
of expressivity they could
if they could produce and what was
needed was something
that could take us up this diagonal path
to to closer
to what human beings are able to achieve
and as i mentioned this
appeared to happen in in 2016 and around
that time when the neural models for
example
first started to appear and they seem to
offer us the opportunity
to to move up this diagonal to make both
flexibility
and naturalness part of our tts
solutions
so i'll just summarize what the
components of a tts system are
um very briefly of course it's it's
commonly believed that there are three
overall categories that can be it can be
broken into text analysis
takes some form of text representation
in and creates uh linguistic features
from this
and these linguistic features are used
throughout the remainder of the
synthesis system
to generate property models and the
processing models then
with the linguistic features are pushed
into the speech synthesizer
to generate synthetic audio
now all these components have been
either completely replaced
or have been significantly modified by
neural technologies
in in this extreme you have the
end-to-end systems where you put text in
you have a neural model
and you have speech outs these these
end-to-end systems
are um very promising but they
they have the difficulty that it's very
difficult to dig in and find out
why the model did what it did so for
some practical reasons
it's often nicer to be able to factorize
these into these different blocks still
so that you can dig in and understand
why one particular
model was doing something and maybe
correct that
and this is of course important for any
production system so there are two
different approaches
they both have their pros and cons
so let's talk about what we're doing in
terms of neural modelling
and the overall approach that we're
taking that that you'll see is applied
typically
to all the things i'm going to talk
about so the basic idea is that you have
uh two neural systems one
on the left-hand side represented by
probably generation
takes in the textual information and
consumes that
uh and generates an intermediate
representation and
the intermediate representation that is
most commonly used is a male spectrogram
a predicted male spectrogram and this
this predicted spectrogram is then
passed into another
neural model in this case the universal
neural vocoder
that then attempts to synthesize from
this predicted spectrogram
a uh human-like audio signal
so that that's the the general approach
now if we dig in a little bit more
to the way uh that we do the uh
representation to the intermediate uh
mel
spectrogram it's it's a it's an encoder
decoder model
uh these are these are quite commonly
used now and there are different
approaches to it but sequence to
sequence modeling is one of the most
common
and the basic idea here is that you'll
have
uh an encoder that will consume
knowledge
uh create some form of embedded vector
that this will be
sent through to the decoder which will
then iteratively
uh expand it out to to the
representation that it wants to create
so a sequence to the sequence of course
there is the
additional um property of adding an
attention
attention um helps the decoder
understand how to move forward
which which property to give a
particular attention to
and it's uh attention has now been
recognized as one of the things that are
needed to make these models
work effectively so that's that's a
that's an additional nuance to the basic
model
and this is going to be our workhorse
for for all the things that we're going
to talk about in
the following slides so let's talk a
little bit about
um where we are so previously of course
we used
concatenative systems they were very
competitive
um so let's play what our
best concat system sounds like
introducing amazon's first custom
electric delivery vehicle
amazon has revealed its first custom
electric delivery vehicle
designed and built in partnership with
rivian and expects to have 10 000 of the
new vans on the road delivering to
customers as early as 2022.
so that's uh our concatenative system
and now let's see how that sounds when
we
use a neural model to generate the same
phrase
introducing amazon's first custom
electric delivery vehicle
amazon has revealed its first custom
electric delivery vehicle
designed and built in partnership with
rivien and expects to have 10 000 of the
new vans on the road delivering to
customers as early as
2022. okay so neural text-to-speech
systems have allowed us
to generate sounds that are smoother
um and more consistent than our
capacitive systems but they still sound
very similar what we need to do now with
these models is demonstrate
that we can put expressive text to
speech system into these technologies
and that's what i'm going to talk about
now
how to add expressivity into
text-to-speech synthesis
again we're going to look at the same
type of model but here we're going to
add in
another element to the attention in this
case
we're going to add in style so not only
are we going to have recordings that are
neutral in style we're going to
add in during training recordings that
expressed
a particular speaking style and the one
we chose initially was
newscaster as a style that people would
recognize as a
as a very distinct uh from neutral style
and also
very pacey how did we do this okay so we
mixed in
different styles and we labeled the
newscaster style as a particular style
um and then we hope that the system
would learn to be able to discriminate
between the two
uh once we've trained it for synthesis
we will pass in a style id
and the system with the appendix to the
attention mechanism
and give an extra cue to the decoder to
hopefully help it synthesize in a way
that expresses that style so again if we
play
play samples if we play the uh neural
neutral style again
introducing amazon's first custom
electric delivery vehicle
amazon has revealed its first custom
electric delivery vehicle
designed and built in partnership with
rivian and expects to have 10 000 of the
new vans on the road delivering to
customers as early as 2022
and now we compare it with our style
driven synthesis
introducing amazon's first custom
electric delivery vehicle
amazon has revealed its first custom
electric delivery vehicle
designed and built in partnership with
rivian and expects to have 10
000 of the new bands on the road
delivering to customers as early as 2022
okay so hopefully you can hear that the
newscaster style is more pacey
and more representative of what a person
would expect
a newscaster to sound like so moving on
from this
what about emotions how can we add
emotions
into synthesis as well as style so we've
looked at ways of using disentanglement
to allow us to add emotions as well as
style properties to speech synthesis
so if we play a neutral style i am
playing a single hand in what looks like
a losing game
by moving through a space of embeddings
we can express
highly excited styles i'm playing a
single hand in what looks like a losing
game
to highly disappoint his files i'm
playing a
single hand in what looks like a losing
game or anything in between
and by selling by doing so we also keep
the naturalness
that we want to to hear from these
neural models
okay so we've talked about style and
emotion and now i want to talk about
semantically aware
in other words we want to add into the
synthesis system
the ability to be able to interpret the
text so some of the intentions of the
author
comes through when we're synthesizing
so it's not just covering the style
we're also trying now to get some word
sense in there
by applying natural language processing
techniques
to our system and if i play this through
you'll see again it's the same
sort of broad scope of the structure
that we've applied before
but here we're now trying to include
word sensor
or language modeling into this to again
help the attention model
understand how much in terms of the
language
you would expect a particular words and
phrases to be given
certain weight and then from this uh to
be able to help the decoder
emphasize particular words in a
particular way so we believe that such
an approach
is is important particularly for what we
call longer form reading
where you've got an extensive material
maybe
multiple paragraphs that it will give
the
reader a sense of being able to
listen and feel that the system is
is really understanding what is speaking
so again if we if we look at the
newscaster style which is a very
expressive style
introducing amazon's first custom
electric delivery vehicle
amazon has revealed its first custom
electric delivery vehicle
designed and built in partnership with
rivien and expects to have 10
000 of the new vans on the road
delivering to customers as early as
2022.
and now let's compare it with our
long-form approach
which isn't as dynamic but hopefully
would allow
a reader to listen to a longer passage
of material
introducing amazon's first custom
electric delivery vehicle
amazon has revealed its first custom
electric delivery vehicle
designed and built in partnership with
ribbian and expects to have 10 000 of
the new bands on the road delivering to
customers as early as 2022.
okay so we've talked about naturalness
expressivity
and adding in semantic knowledge into
text
but now i want to talk about making the
system aware
of its context adapting to the reasons
that it's saying
in a dialogue in a discourse so taking
into consideration
the uh intentions of the dialogue
systems
and the emotions and feelings of the
interlocutor
and to do this with was just starting to
develop such systems
but here is a graph to demonstrate what
we're doing and you'll recognize
elements of it already from what's in
the previous slide but if we take an
alexa skill what we want to be able to
do
is take a generic response like hello
and be able to rephrase that in a way
that makes it more dynamic so for
example hi
how can i help you or some other
different variant
that reflects the intentions of the
skill
um and different parts of the dialogue
to reflect the previous response from
the user so that we
give the the application the sense of of
listening and adapting
to to what was spoken previously and
then of course use the language we use
is only part of it so if we want to say
something that is very
uh excited that's fantastic you you know
you need to
marry the word fantastic with the level
of voice expressivity
that's fantastic so um we need to
change the way we speak to reflect
the intention and the word usage and for
that we have a spoken language model
uh that's similar to what we said before
when now we're adding in
uh knowledge about the application
knowledge about the state
knowledge about the intention and giving
this to the attention
mechanism again to help select different
styles
of different uh levels of prominence um
and different uh
emotional states to reflect where the
application feels it is in in the
discourse so let's
let's listen to an example where we just
play a static neutral
response very happy to help let's find
something you like on amazon music
how about something from the 80s does
that work
and now if we apply the technology which
is trying to be context aware
very happy to help let's find something
you like on amazon music
how about something from the 80s living
on a prayer by bon jovi
does that work okay so
that's a very quick overview of where we
are with the text-to-speech system
and now i'll hand it over to my
colleague xiao who will tell you about
acoustic event detection